what looks at first glance like ancient
art is actually a full-blown written
language but what does this homegrown
Mesoamerican script teach us about the
history of writing a Maya stone worker
h's elaborate rows of characters onto a
steel ax a tall stone brought in from
far away that's now standing straight up
in the middle of the city the characters
he's carving look more like detailed
pictures than writing but don't let that
fool you take a look at this block it
means mountain but it's not a logograph
standing for mountain it's not a rebus
symbol for think of a word that rhymes
with SH Mountain it's actually a block
of to sound symbols that spell the word
wheats the Maya word for mountain that's
great for climbers but chocolate lovers
may instead prefer to sample these three
symbols that together spell the word
cacao cocoa there's a nifty shortcut
here this bit doesn't even mean kha it's
actually a syllable multiplier or
iteration mark if you want the fancy
name Shh I think you're being watched
over there in the jungle
maybe not hmm
major moments in the history of writing
both of these Maya glyphs combined
syllable characters into blocks to write
words this is full-fledged
sound writing these aren't logographs
that happen to be read as sounds they
are sounds sounds capable of writing any
syllable in the language in a full
syllabary like the classical Maya script
there are separate characters for just
about every possible syllable in the
language no longer must you invent new
word characters you can make do with a
much smaller set of syllable characters
nice but syllable writing comes with its
own set of problems here's a glyph
that's quite useful around these parts
Jaguar the word is actually belong but
have you noticed something about the
Mayan syllabary consonant plus vowel
consonant plus vowel more consonants
plus more vowels all of these syllables
Indian vowels how in the world are
you supposed to write the Lomb in below
Shifty's scripty syllabaries have
grappled with this problem and settled
on two solutions one leave out the final
letter just ignore it the term for this
is under spelling because you're not
fully spelling the word and it's a good
solution because you know ignoring your
problems makes them go away option to
spell the last letter with an extra
syllable they use a syllable that just
repeats the last vowel so that we know
we can just ignore the final vowel this
gets called the echo vowel Mayan likes
number two a lot so cacao is cacao WA
well kha times two
waa wheats the mountain is actually with
Si and your new pet balaam is spelled
Bala MA cross out the echo vowels and
the words practically read themselves
your new friend pulls you along to show
you another project he's working on
Anna MAHT a codex that's a paper book
yes he has paper and yes books but
that's not what's got him excited he
folds open the book he's working on
maybe to share new ideas no to brag
about how inventive and potentially
efficient his writing system is no for
his people the invention of the new
wasn't about ditching the old he shows
you how creative he's been with the
characters you learned he shows you a
mountain and calls it wheats and then a
Jaguar and calls it
Balam logographs wait a second you stop
and ask him which is the correct way to
write Balam he writes ba llama you ask
him to write it again and he writes the
logograph but with the syllable and
again but he writes the logograph plus
two syllables
he smiles mischievously they're all
Balam this is what he's proud of he can
write the same word even the same
syllable in different ways and
combinations without repeating himself
creative but his use of logographs plus
syllables recalls the tension between
sound writing and meaning writing
meaningful determinative z' helped us
choose the right pronunciation for our
rebus character and
Mayon logographs can still do that but
the helping hand goes both ways the
syllabary can also clarify the sounds
you should make when you read aloha
graph here's the character jagwire but
add a couple extra syllable hints and
you make it clear that we're meant to
read this glyph as ba llama - the echo
vowel so Balaam these are phonetic
complements pronunciation clues sitting
comfortably alongside logographs if
that's all too complex just remember
that you can write everything in
syllables but before you have time to
settle into this land of Balaam and
cacao to practice those syllables a
sandy wind starts blowing in from the
east
a familiar reminder from a faraway land
where even more dramatic changes are
about to shape the future of writing